so to understand query rules a bit more
you're going to add another filter to
the query in your query playground
method so now here we get all the
conference's sorted by name filter on
the city is London we filter on topics
is medical innovations filter on month
is six but now I'm going to add one more
filter I want to filter on max attendees
greater than 10 now I'm going to run
this query on localhost I'm going to try
it out in the api's Explorer oops got an
error how did that happen oh look it's
got some good information in here if you
can narrow read it carefully remember
you can copy and paste it into an editor
that renders HTML to make it easier to
read so it's now your turn to add an
inequality filter add a filter for max
attendees greater than 10 and then go
ahead and try the query on localhost and
test it out using the api's Explorer I'm
guessing that you're going to get an
error but what caused the error is it
because the first sort order is on name
but the inequality filter is on max
attendees or is it because the composite
index does not exist or is it because
you have too many inequality filters in
one query